لقد أخبرتني للتو من قبل هيئة الصحة في هونج كونج
أنني تم نقلي إلى
الحجر الصحي الحكومي لأن أحد
أصدقائي أثبت إصابتي بفيروس كورونا
، لقد كنت أعزل
نفسي في غرفتي منذ أن اكتشفت أن
صديقي كان مصابًا بالفيروس.  إيجابي وهذا
هو سبب الفوضى ، فقد كان هناك بعض
التأخير في نقل الأشخاص إلى مراكز الحجر الصحي
لأن العديد من الأشخاص في هونغ
كونغ أثبتت إصابتهم مؤخرًا ، لذا فقد
تم للتو في غرفتي على
شرفتي في شاي واحد في هونغ  كونغ في
انتظار المكالمة التي
تم التقاطها لي بالحافلة لتأخذني
إلى الحجر الصحي ،
لقد شعرت ببعض السريالية لأخذي
عبر الشارع خارج
مبنى شقتي بواسطة عامل طبي مناسب تمامًا للمواد الخطرة
اجتذبناه  بعض الإطلالات المضحكة
وعند القدوم إلى المخيم ، كان الأمر
أشبه بالذهاب إلى السجن
[موسيقى]
، لم يكن الأمر تمامًا كما كنت أتوقع ،
إنه أشبه بنوع من شقق الاستوديو اللطيفة ،
هذه واحدة من عشرات
وعشرات الوحدات الصغيرة المتطابقة
عند الرغبة في التأرجح المنخفض في منتزه العطلات السابق هذا
في المخيم ، يُسمح لنا بالخروج
أثناء ارتداء أقنعة الوجه ويمكننا أيضًا
التواصل مع بعضنا البعض طالما أننا
نبقى على مسافة صحية بعيدًا
عنك
[موسيقى] أنت [موسيقى]